I believe that there's 25 people
listening right now that are in a thread
where their buddies are saying you
should do fantasy football fulltime
you're the smartest and best one in are
cre you're funny but they're like nah
I'm telling you for the 25 out of the
million that listen this podcast please
use this as a sign as like you know what
it my friends have been telling me
for 2 years I've secretly been thinking
about it for two months use this m this
dude first Tik Tok the first one I'll
never forget it was a Wednesday night
7:52 p.m. I'm working in the gym I was
like you know what like no one's coming
and it I'm just going to make a
video so I made it's quick 15sec video
post it didn't think anything of it the
next morning I woke up and it was just
going ballistic